make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so here's something cool that's cat
well I'll talk about at the end of this
video the DC story this was like DC's
first real shot at a zombies story they
didn't involve the Green Lantern's right
we got blackest night which was
essentially a zombie story but blackest
night serve the purpose of just
basically allowing DC to create a soft
reboot right to basically resurrect
everybody who was dead and then keep the
ones who mattered the most right that
was really all it was like it's night
brightest day tell those two things ran
in tandem this is it like a blackest
night story right it's just it was just
a straight-up zombie story that's what
deceased was but the cool thing is is DC
comics really seems to have just picked
up on how much people loved this and the
good thing is we've had all these little
miniseries but we also have this right
this is hope at World's End I hope it
worlds in is like a companion series
right so this gives us essentially what
was going on between the pages or
between the issues of the main DC story
right so you get DC so number one and
then this fits in there somewhere
you know you get DC's number two that's
fits in as well all the way up into the
end and then from what I understand will
get more hope of world to end stories
and those will I kind of fit in to the
rest of all that stuff by showing us
more about what was going on because the
reality is that as cool as deceased was
it felt light on content right I mean
you guys remember like like DC's came
out and it's like god there's so many
unanswered questions here like like I
need more and it was a really smart play
by DC to play it out that way right but
what this does here is this initially
picks up with Jimmy Olsen and Jimmy
Olsen is kind of going through here and
talking about how he never wanted to be
a war photographer right but like here
they are in that moment he's now a war
photographer and he wanted to keep
memories right he wanted to keep
pictures of the various superheroes and
their various escapades but more so than
that just the small moments and this
isn't see this is cool
this is why Tom Taylor is such an
amazing writer right let's let's deviate
away from this for a second let's talk
about him justice right when Tom Taylor
wrote injustice he knocked it out of the
park why that story was amazing because
it gave us all the characters that we
know and love from DC and some of whom
we didn't even know about before and
then brought him to us and then took us
on like this emotional roller coaster
right with like all these twists and
turns in these insane moments like
learning Harley Quinn had a daughter and
she had to give her daughter up just
different things like that right like
there were just these amazing amazing
amazing moans
that took place in that story and this
is much the same way right the idea of
Jimmy Olsen going through and not really
hanging up pictures of the conflict but
just hanging up pictures of like Wonder
Woman and Martian Manhunter both of them
eating like you know snacks and like
Blue Beetle doing his thing and like
Damian Wayne Jonathan Kent you know like
these these small little moments here
and there are awesome because this is
what's really to be remembered right the
superhero is out there you know I'm sure
they had escapades and they fought
villains bad guys so on and so forth but
what matters the most to Jimmy Olsen are
like this small little moment and so
what we end up doing is that we're that
little segment took place in the present
day this jumps back to about two weeks
beforehand at the Daily Planet
and it picks up of course with you know
Jimmy Olsen having gotten pictures of
Superman beating the crap out of
doomsday at some point in time of course
before the events of DCs kicked off and
the result is that where Perry White is
kind of celebrating the fact that Jimmy
also can get those shots they're shots
that are you know gonna make the
headlines those are the kind of shots to
get people pull the surprises different
things like that the result is that in
the middle of this suddenly we get that
ding and then we essentially have the
anti-life virus that just suddenly
spreads right so this happens the moment
that basically cyborg ends up
inadvertently spreading the virus across
the Internet and so suddenly everybody
starts transforming and it's like it
happens in instance right and that's
kind of the crazy thing is we sort of
knew how it took place right away we got
those little moments there but it's kind
of cool to see this from the perspective
of Jimmy Olsen like the world is falling
apart around him and he's just like
taking pictures right because that's
what that's what he does it's the only
thing he knows how to do but people are
like within seconds people are just like
rima t realizing into these monsters
losing their minds and so he grabs the
individuals who that he can who have not
been exposed yet and then yanked them
away and basically puts them into the
broadcast room now
this is why Jimmy Olsen snapped this
picture and his wife's a genius shot
Jimmy Olsen took a picture of them of
all these people out there looking at
the you know their phones and so on and
so forth now the important thing about
this is the anti-life virus spreads
through digital information right it
spreads through like phones and
different things like that from what we
gather it does not spread through like a
picture of that and that kind of makes
sense yes picture store digital day they
store you know information but only in
relation to the image that was shot
right like if you if you go and you take
a picture it is not like physically
store any information there so like if
you take a picture of a computer
you're not gonna store any information
from the computer on the picture right
that's not that's not how that works and
so it's cool to kind of see that little
bit of a twist there to see that little
bit of involvement but more so than that
it gives Jimmy Olsen the realization of
how it's all kicking
the people were looking at their phones
that they were looking at their
computers they were looking at tablets
all those different things it's
spreading through personal devices and
so where Jimmy Olsen's like phones like
immediately you know cat goes to go to
grab her phone at the S cache she goes
to grab her phone and Jimmy Olsen says
no phones and throws it out the window
right like no phones everybody stay off
their personal devices that's one of the
cool things about Jimmy Olsen is he's
smart right he's not just a guy who
takes pictures and he's really good at
it then he probably has a cool Instagram
account he's really really really really
smart and so with that you know with him
picking up on that quite you know very
very fast from there it's kind of like
okay the world's devolve into chaos all
around them people are trying to get
into the to the broadcast room door it
basically barricade the door as best
they can and then suddenly there's quiet
and when Jimmy Olsen cracks the door
open
Superman's there so we know this is the
moment when Superman shows up to the
Daily Planet and it's basically there
alongside like Green Lantern and all
those characters and trying to rescue
people and and it's and it's cool
because you know where Jimmy Olsen says
I didn't really use my my communicator
but I didn't use my signal watch because
I felt like there were other people who
were needed which is true Superman
ultimately of course ended up rescuing
Jimmy and just says hey I'll be back as
soon as I can and what we get is this
kind of play-by-play in a relatively
quick amount of time while they were
there inside the Daily Planet the idea
that like Batman fell Nightwing like Hal
Jordan all those guys basically ended up
falling ended up dying right that was
one of the biggest shocks to the first
issue but by the time the first issue
ends is the end of Bruce Wayne and like
it really kind of threw us off guard
because historically speaking in DC
Bruce Wayne's the MacGuffin right he's
the means by which this story ends right
okay nobody else can figure out what's
going on you know Bruce Wayne can do it
because the plot calls for it right
that's kind of how that that whole thing
worked and so with him being out of the
picture right off the bat it's like okay
well what hope do they have which I
really think speaks volumes more about
the nature of Batman that anything else
right Batman dies well then everybody's
gonna die cuz how else are they gonna
live you know it was kind of a crazy
little thing there but of course as we
know we ended up having Superman the
other members of the Justice League who
showed up basically ended up where at
least the remainders of the Justice
League ended up protecting everybody in
the Daily Planet when Captain Atom
exploded right when he detonated ended
up kill you know wiping out three
different cities including metropolis
you know just different things like that
but Jimmy Olsen is watching all of this
go on and that's what makes this so cool
is because when we were reading it we
were looking at it from the perspective
of just us as a person right well we saw
Superman we saw him dealing with Lois
Lane the idea that like so much of their
other city had been lost over the entire
city had been lost so many of their
friends had
killed different things like that but we
saw it from the pernil through the eyes
of Superman or through the eyes of Lois
Lane or something like that seeing it
through the eyes of Jimmy Olsen is
almost like just being there in the
moment and watching it happen and that's
what's so cool is because he's just kind
of like just because a guy is you know
just cuz bullets bounce off a guy does
not mean that like he's invulnerable
right this guy is you know there's
different types of vulnerability
vulnerability emotionally mentally
things like that and while Superman's
not broken
he's certainly hurting but what he
understands is that he did well and he
could be good you know mourn the dead
and there'll be time to do that in the
moment right now it's focusing on the
living it's doing what needs to be done
and that's where he tasks you know
Dinoland you know the new Green Lantern
that's where each has her with these
things but again it's kind of a crazy
moment because again like Superman
basically takes off you know and that's
where we you know and when Jimmy Olsen
gets the shot of Superman leaving so of
course you know this is before Superman
ends up becoming infected you know we
kind of get this thing where Jimmy Olsen
is just kind of back basically taking
pictures developing these shots and then
hanging them up so that all these these
heroes the Fallen heroes are remembered
right now poison ivy in Harley Quinn
they're viewed as having already been
dead we know that's not the case so we
know Jimmy Olsen doesn't have all the
facts and that's important because we
see crypto there and I would love to
believe that crypto is not dead right I
would love to believe he's not one of
the anti alive zombies I would love to
believe that he's still alive because
nobody ever wants to see the dog die but
nonetheless the cool thing about all
this and the big revelation that we get
here is that what DC is doing with
regards to the deceased event is they're
launching or at least with a DC story
they're launching an event called the
anti life war where basically all the
various heroes who were left heroes
villains whoever individuals who have
power they're all basically going to be
there to like fight off the anti-life
monsters more or less this is awesome
because when you keep in mind everything
that's happened Superman is still out
there the last we saw he flew into the
Sun right that was basically it the
various other superheroes ended up
traveling to OA to the home of the Green
Lantern's right this is also taking into
account released we have to consider if
this is relatively close to the rest of
the DC mythos you've got all the other
Lantern course right so this could be
like very very similar to injustice in a
lot of different ways right but it could
just be this massive event that DC's
doing it's cool right like it's amazing
and it's one of the best ideas that DC's
had in a long long time but without
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here too
comments explain it make sure you guys
at the sub but
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
purse
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]